when I was a girl my brother told me it
was made with a thousand swords from
Aegon's fallen enemies hi everyone its
Charlie this is going to be my Game of
Thrones finale video so here we go we
have so much to talk about if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos I'll start talking about the game
of Thrones prequel series which is a
completely different creative team but
that'll be a little bit later this week
after we get done talking about the
finale and processing everything there's
a new round of the HBO now giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about the
finale on the video obviously a spoiler
warning for everything in the game of
Thrones finale because there's so much
to get through I just did this as a top
20 video instead of like the normal top
15 or top 10 that I would do so starting
with number 20 the title of the episode
in the new intro they changed some of
the things about the intro because of
all the damage to King's Landing last
week the title of the episode maybe
you're not surprised by this was the
Iron Throne
HBO's whole marketing campaign for
season 8 was for the throne so it makes
sense that they would reference the Iron
Throne in the finale title in some way I
was hoping it would be a reference to
one of the books but I feel like this is
also probably acceptable it was either
going to be a dream of spring or some
reference like a time of wolves which
used to be the old title the George R
Martin had for a dream of spring until
he changed it so in a way it is a time
for wolves now because the stark family
has almost you could say won the Game of
Thrones effectively even though the
stark that wound up on the throne wasn't
the obvious choice as I said they
changed Kings Landing in the intro the
little model of it to reflect all the
Battle Damage from episode five so the
gates have been blown open the red keep
had been torn down just a little bit but
as we all saw during the episode
surprisingly the only thing in the
throne room left standing was the iron
throne itself the other thing that I
liked about the intro is that you
basically pick up with Tyrion doing
almost the exact same thing that he did
during season 7 episode 4 witnessing all
the horror of what Daenerys have done
burning all those Lannister troops only
now it's on a much much bigger scale so
the way they filmed it was also really
cool to the put you in Tyrion said just
to give you a sense for the horror and
all the shock that he was going through
in this moment number 19 they come on
grey worm who's executing all the
Lannister soldiers that they've captured
and defeated Daenerys has commanded us
to everyone who
serve Cersei Lannister so that's what
we're going to do and even though it
looks like he and Johnson we're going to
throw down into a fight I didn't
actually expect there to be any fighting
I think they just wanted to let you know
that the unsullied we're going to continue
to be a big problem for them in the
future regardless of what would happen
to Daenerys so I know a lot of you are
upset about what happened to Jon Snow at
the end I'll talk about that don't worry
we'll get into all the endings for all
the stark characters but you have to
remember that the unsullied would have
always been a big problem had they not
given them that win number 18 Tyrion
walks back through the wreckage of the
red keep when he walks back through this
room he's mostly thinking about his time
as hand to the king because that was all
season 2 then it's time there with Tywin
Lannister when Tywin became hand to the
king so he spent a lot of time in this
room here then obviously this sort of
brings it full circle when he becomes
the new hand of the king at the end of
the episode but we're still mostly in
shock and horror mode so he obviously
takes the torch down into the basement
to the escape route to see if Jaime and
Cersei got out and it finds their bodies
so the music of the episode finally cuts
in once he sees their faces and starts
breaking down crying and it's a remix of
the rains of castamere which they've
kind of been using as a Lannister theme
for the past couple of seasons so pretty
much the first half of the episode is
all really really sad everyone's either
completely horrified at what's happened
or they're just crying open it like you
saw the northern soldier that they
walked by on their way to the red cape
just breaking down into tears
nobody except for the unsullied and the
Dothraki can handle it but they're super
jazzed up they're like oh yeah this is
going to be awesome this new regime we're going to go around and liberate the world
so number 17 Daenerys makes her grand
entrance and I love the way that they
shot her in front of drogon so when his
wings unfurl it's almost like she's the
dragon you've woken the dragon like
Viserys used to say you don't want to
wake the dragon do you and she gives
them her best dictator speech so it's
his grand victory celebration she gets
them all stoked up about this new
campaign that she's going to start all
over the world and suddenly it starts to
sink in like you look at Taran and Jon
Snow looking at each other I loved a lot
of the nonverbal acting that they did
the first half of the episode when
they're just kind of reacting not sure
what to do about Daenerys I'll talk
about what happened to the Dothraki and
the unsullied at the end of the episode
too because they're like there's this
big idea of a campaign that they're not
really going on anymore
Daenerys names off a couple big places
that we haven't visited and Game of
Thrones yet there's a lot of
places on the southern parts of the map
that we've never actually visited like
so thorough so I think that the prequel
series is going to pick up with some of
those cheering quits his hand of the
king which seems pretty logical it seems
like he was building to that moment like
I can't have any of this but predictably
she arrests him because she found out
about him freeing Jamie so after she
gives John Snow a look like she
registers his disappointment Arya shows
up next to John like a ninja and people
start planting the idea to get rid of
Daenerys into John's head you have to
her there's no way that Sansa is
ever going to bend the knee remember
during episode two when they were
talking about potentially letting the
north be independent and Daenerys just
recoiled at the thought like there's no
way that she's going to allow the north to
be free John snow seemed like he was
genuinely surprised with her skills I
don't think that he ever saw her steal a
face though so maybe someday she'll talk
to him about that because at the end of
the episode even though she says I'm not
coming back it's always possible that a
future version of Arya way down the road
could come back and visit a very old
version of Jon Snow 15 John goes to
visit Tyrion they make a couple of jokes
there's a couple references to dialogue
from early in the series he also
references something that maester aemon
said love is the death of duty
so Amon was actually talking about all
the times that he had to not go help his
family after he had taken the black
remember maester aemon is very old so he
took the black after the period of the
black by rebellion after that settled
down with the Bloodraven who also took
the black at the same time but he was
much older at the time before he became
the three-eyed raven maester aemon took
the black when he was a young man
so all these subsequent Wars and
problems in the Targaryen family he just
had to sit out and watch it all play
while he was up at the wall one of his
great regrets most recently was during
Robert's rebellion he wasn't able to
come to de nurse's aid he was talking
about a Targaryen alone in the world
being a very terrible thing a lot of
Tyrians conversation with Jon Snow is
referencing things that people were
trying to deal with after last week's
episode so there were a lot of people
after Daenerys burned King's Landing
that were trying to point to all the
things that foreshadowed that she was
going to be doing something like this
John sort of takes the voice of all the
other people trying to defend Daenerys
he actually does try to defend Daenerys
his actions for a brief period is just
that stupid stubborn Ned Stark level
honor that always gets him into trouble
she's my queen it will be for her to
decide
who sits on the Iron Throne the only
thing that really gets John is when
Tyrion kind of slips in that line about
his sister's do you think that your
sisters will ever bend the knee so it's
not really clear what moment exactly Jon
Snow makes up his mind but I think it's
while he's walking to the iron throne
room by the time he has that last speech
with Daenerys before he decides what
he's going to do even though it totally
wasn't necessary I love the scene of
John trying to slowly edge his way by
drogon who was just sleeping underneath
that pile of snow and it was snow so I
will talk about Daenerys his vision in
the house of the undying number 14
though they obviously pay off that
vision with a couple of minor edits like
they destroyed way more of the throne
room I think that was just to be truer
to the actual damage that she had done
and to let more light in because it's
very dark during that scene when she's
in the house of the undying so
miraculously the only thing that
survived in that room was the iron
throne itself and just like her vision
she reaches out and touches it with the
hand this is almost the exact same scene
Emilia Clarke actually said that this
was the very last scene that she filmed
it was just a small insert of her hand
which is obviously the scene of her
reaching to touch the iron throne the
thing that she's fought for this whole
time just like in the vision she does
not get a chance to sit on the Iron
Throne though before Jon Snow walks in
and you know whatever she was feeling in
that moment earlier when she gave him
that look she's completely past it she's
drinking her own kool-aid she's excited
to build this new world by force it
seems and Jon Snow is still just trying
to talk her out of it what about all the
children have you seen any of the
destruction on the streets even though I
never felt like Emilia Clarke and Kit
Harington had great chemistry together
so I never really bought them as a
couple I did love this scene obviously
they had to nail it because it was such
an important scene so I do think that
regardless of what you think about the
script they did a great job of
performing that number 13 though Jon
Snow obviously says you'll always be my
queen and winds up her I think
the exact moment that he finally decided
that he had to her was when she
said those other people when he
references what about all the other
people and what they think is a good
idea is when Daenerys says those other
people don't get to decide so it's
basically her giving her really great
tyrant speech having drunken all of her
own kool-aid then fulfilling the
prophecy from the next part of her
vision of the house the undying before
she actually gets to sit on the Iron
Throne
she walks through this door into the
afterlife where she sees Khal Drogo and
her baby
Rago that died predictably number 12
drogon senses that something's wrong
comes to find an heiress you do kind of
think that he's going to John for a
second until he just unleashes flame
everywhere in his greep
I know it seemed weird that he melted
the Iron Throne specifically like you
wonder how smart he is like is he
burning that purpose or is he just
breathing out flame because he's in
distress I think it's more that he's in
distress and they just filmed it in a
way that seen Quinn Satana like oh he
just happens to be melting the Iron
Throne this thing that Daenerys had been
fighting for her whole life I mostly
expected going into the episode that
they would destroy the Iron Throne in
one way or another and the only way to
melt it down like that is to use dragon
fire because when Aegon was forging the
Iron Throne after the conquest he had to
use balerion the black dread to help
smelt all the swords it actually took
them months in the books the story is is
that it was actually Smith's that made
it like you Smith would make a sword so
they made the Iron Throne but because
they're not artists and craftsmen this
way the real Iron Throne of the books is
so asymmetrical looking whatever lines
of dialogue to the story she tells that
Viserys told me as a child about the
iron throne a thousand swords imagine
what that looks like to a little girl it
just the writers making a really meta
joke about their version of the iron
throne because this is obviously not a
thousand swords this is what a thousand
swords looks like but the reason why
they didn't make this version of the
iron throne for the TV show is because
it'd be way too unwieldy to film so they
just had to make something that would
fit on camera better drogon flies away
with her body headed east we don't know
what he's going to be doing going
forward but bran makes a reference
saying maybe I can find him likes I
think that's a joke about him
potentially working the dragon because
it's been such a big fan theory for so
long in him just using his normal
abilities to warg Ravens and other
animals to just get information when he
wants it there's a small time jump we
learned that Tyrion and Jon Snow have
been imprisoned by the unsullied for
several weeks because you see all this
beard growth on Tyrion so number 11
there's been enough time for a great
council to form and you have all the
different realms being represented by a
lot of people that are familiar they're
a couple of new people here - there's
Sansa and Arya representing the north
Gendry representing the Stormlands with
one of his new bannermen Edmure Tully
representing the Riverlands Brienne and
Davos I don't know
exactly which region they're going to be
representing but you're a Greyjoy
representing the Iron Islands sweet
Robin and Yan Royce representing the
Vale and then the new Prince of Dorne I
don't know who this actor is I don't
know which family he belongs to if he's
a Martell or if he's one of their
cousins but they're basically trying to
placate the unsullied because the
unsullied in the Dothraki still control
King's Landing but there's a northern
army outside the gates because they want
to get Jon Snow back Davos even offers
grey worm in the unsullied land in the
reach to form their own house and he's
like nope not having it but he wants
justice he's out for blood so they have
to make the deal with them so a lot of
this gets into the logic of how they
send Jon Snow back to the north but they
need a new king so number 10
Tyrion gives his big speech about why
bran should be king brand thebroken
first of his name because stories are
what bring all them together and bran
has all the best stories he literally a
living memory of everything in human
history so of course he has the best
stories but remember he's also the
keeper of everyone's secrets as well so
the other reason why he's a really good
King is because of his ability to gather
information like he does kind of need a
master of whispers as he says later but
because he can ward the Ravens and other
animals he can get whatever information
he wants from anywhere he even says why
do you think I came down this whole way
when they offer him the crown because
he's basically saying that I saw this in
the future I knew it was going to happen
I'm sure we'll be talking about the
logic of picking bran as king going
forward because a lot of people were
expecting Jon Snow to sit on the Iron
Throne so you guys can let me know in
the comments what do you think about the
logic of the choice and you know given
some of Brande skills I think as long as
he has the right people around him which
it kind of seems like he does he should
be okay in the way that Isaac Hempstead
right explains it is is that this
version of bran
having had his powers for a couple
seasons now has gotten better at using
them and is therefore more able to
interact with people like an actual
person would wear as way back at the
beginning of season seven when he first
came back to Winterfell he was a little
bit more like a turnip all hail King
turnip first of his name big changes to
the round going forward though number
nine Sansa claims that the North has
vowed too hard and lost too much they're
never going to bend the knee so she wants
to remain independent bran
now acting as king allows that to happen
he says okay fine you get to be
independent so Sansa is technically
Queen in the north they even cheer her
at the end of the episode when they put
the crown on her head just like they
cheered Johnson
when they named him king in the north at
the end of season 6 but all the other
realms are still going to be part of
brands new regime including Dorne so
they have a joke about it when Tyrion
says all hail bran king of the 6
kingdoms number 8 though big
surprise brand names Tyrion his hand of
the king and his penance for all the bad
things that he's done he reminds them
about Shaye about Tywin
even the unsullied still won his head
because of his role in Daenerys his
death but bran says that he's going to
serve penance by helping make the realm
better one day at a time for the rest of
his life this is one of those
interesting scenarios where I feel like
either one would have been a good option
for Tyrians character as part of his
character arc he does work really well
as hand of the king but it also would
have been an appropriately bittersweet
ending for his character would he have
been executed by Daenerys or the
unsullied 7 the compromise with the
unsullied to keep them from starting
another protracted war in King's Landing
is to make Jon Snow take the black his
consequence for Daenerys so if
you were confused by why they had to do
that it was because the own so lead had
almost the exact same number of troops
that all of the other northern Allied
forces have and even Yara Greyjoy was
still team Daenerys so even though they
kind of throw Jon Snow under the bus I
think that Jon Snow accepts it knowing
that he belongs in the north like
tormund says and he's just so sad about
what he had to do to Daenerys because he
really did love her if it wasn't clear I
know obviously they didn't have a lot of
chemistry together as actors so number 6
we start to get all of our goodbyes this
is sort of the Lord of the Rings
versions of the endings from Return of
the King where you get four or five
different endings for all the different
characters starting with the first one
grey worm watches Jon Snow walked by
still hates his guts but he tells the
other unsullied that they're headed down
to Knauth which is basically him
fulfilling his promise to missandei it
seems like the Dothraki are either
headed to the reach as part of da bosses
offer just giving them some land or
they're headed back to the east back to
the great grass sea five all the stark
children get their final goodbye Sansa
Arya and bran John says Arya is welcome
to come visit him like I said but it
doesn't seem like Arya is planning on
coming back anytime in the next 10 to 20
years she references her line of
dialogue from season 6 I think it was
either episode 8 or one of the middle
episodes where she's talking about
what's west of Westeros so if we're
talking about satisfying conclusions for
characters I feel like Arya's conclusion
is pretty satisfying sonses
makes sense as well we all kind of
expected her to become queen of the
north for bran becomes the new commander
of the Kingsguard wearing the golden
armor she looks through the white book
of names she sees Arthur Dayne Barristan
Selmy and then Jaime Lannister and
continues filling in the rest of his
great deeds the last couple of seasons
the really interesting thing about
brianne's love story with Jamie and her
becoming the Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard is it also mirrors Barristan
Selmy --zz story because he was
commander of the Kingsguard for a long
time Brienne did not get to be with the
person that she loved so it was destined
to be tragic romance Barristan Selmy was
also in love with ashara dayne
as a young person but did not get to be
with her because she herself when
she learned of Arthur Danes fate at the
Tower of joy she threw herself from the
battlements three is the new small
council so tyrion has a funny moment
he's sort of settling in and obviously
it's a big callback to season two when
he became hand of the king during the
early seasons but his small council is
now bran who is master of coin they're
going to finance the reconstruction of
King's Landing because of all that
damage Davos is the new master of ships
Samwell is the new grand maester I felt
like that was a very appropriate choice
and then obviously they say that they
need a new master of laws a new master
of whisperers in a new master of war and
big surprise bran got that bigger castle
he wound up getting Highgarden the only
thing that I was not really happy about
with this scene was them actually doing
the Lord of the Rings ending where Frodo
is finishing Bilbo's book o Lord of the
Rings and he writes it down Oh
maester ebro's finished his book about
the wars after Robert's rebellion I
helped him with the title it's called A
Song of Ice and Fire
maybe you laughed during that scene but
I felt like they could have done without
that joke also Tyrion tries to tell his
honeycomb brothel story again I'll do a
separate video talking about that too
because I think we've actually figured
what the story out is Podrick is also a
part of the Kingsguard you find two and
he's the one who is now charged with
wheeling bran all over the red keep
wherever he wants to go number two is a
time for wolves the Ascension of the
stark children so remember like I said
George are Morton's original title for
the final book and A Song of Ice and
Fire
was going to be called a time for wolves
Sansa being crowned Queen in the north
wearing a new gray dress this looks kind
of like the heart tree because it's got
those red leaves all over it Arya still
has her Valyrian dagger
is on the ship with the Starck sigil
sailing west of Westeros to the
mysterious western continent that we
don't really know anything about then
John arrives at Castle black and becomes
the new 1000 Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch he's both the nine hundred
and ninety 8th Lord Commander then
remember he passed the Duty on to EDD
who became the 999th Lord Commander so
now that Jon Snow is back he's even
number 1,000 so you kind of see how they
did that ghost is there he gives him all
the good boy pets and hugs that he
deserves so we finally got that I was
really happy that they finally had a
ghost scene at the end but the number
one there final scene is of them walking
north of the wall taking the wildlings
back to what is now their territory
again and you see this little green
plant growing up right next to the wall
I think that's just a reference to a
dream of spring as in things are getting
warmer they're getting better everything
that was destroyed during the war with
the White Walkers and then with each
other in the realm the Civil War is
going to grow back but you notice that
the theme song that they're playing is
actually a remix of the stark theme
mixed with the official game of Thrones
theme they also played a remix of the
Game of Thrones theme when tenaris was
touching the Iron Throne earlier -
they're also walking into the haunted
forest which was the very first place
that the show started in the pilot
episode the haunted forest was where
that first big scene where they saw the
White Walkers was where they open the
pilot episode I know you're all asking
the big question how close is this
ending to George RR Martin's ending in
the books I will do a separate video
about that tomorrow because a lot of it
will be the same but there will be some
differences so don't worry that'll be a
whole separate video there's so much to
unpack and process about the finale
I still don't know how I feel about it
it's going to take me a couple days to
figure it out I will do a couple more
videos talking a little bit more about
the ending in what's next for the
characters going forward because like
Arya Sansa Jon they're all still alive
don't forget about the bonus episode
that's airing next Sunday - I'll do a
regular episode video for that just like
I would for any other Game of Thrones
episode but thank you so much this has
been so fun I can't wait to start
talking about the game of Thrones
prequel series I'll start doing that
later this week sometime but leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below will you wait for
everything click here for my episode 5
video and click here for my episode 4
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!